[Music]
so react clog is a memory leak by
definition so we have to opt into it
and we can opt into it using react log
react log enable
and so i'll go ahead and enable that now
and then we can go ahead and
run our shiny application you know
no problem just like we're used to doing
and this one is the you know the old
faithful example that we're used to
seeing of all of the um
waiting times and so we can change the
bin count and the plot updates
great
we can then view the react log by doing
command fn3
for me
and uh might be like option or control
fn3 for windows i can't quite remember
but your react log will show up in a
separate window
and
there's lots going on here but for just
quick quick look we can see our input
bins that we had on the left
and on the right we can see our output
of our um
distribution plot a dist plot from the
application
and let's take a look so
um
the way that react log works is it flows
from left
to right
and we kind of i kind of made the pieces
so that they kind of fit in like a
puzzle so you can have your inputs here
on the left
and they can join into your reactive
values in the middle
so it joins in there and needs to be
finished off with an output value
on the far right
in this case there is a theme counter
here but that's not having any outputs
listen to it so that's why it's all the
way on the right so we kind of
align right on all the values
but theme counter we can ignore um we're
mainly just interested in the output of
the disk plot the react log if we look
let's just kind of walk through the top
of the
this status bar
so we have the eight navigation buttons
at the top the first and last are
traversing between marked steps we
haven't done that yet and we'll come
back to that later
the next ones is a tall green bar that's
this tall green bar here which is when
shiny was idle for at least you know a
millisecond it declared that it was idle
and then the short green bar is an
output
so an output calculation and you can
jump between prior and previous outputs
so you may calculate five outputs
and then shiny becomes idle so you may
want to jump in between to see how your
reactive updates
but the ones that i use a lot are these
middle two which is previous step and
next step
and
you know i don't like to use the mouse
that often so we can actually use the
right arrow and left arrow and you can
hold it
and you can hold it back and the key
caster is showing that i was holding
that there
so that's pretty exciting
react log defaults to the first time
that shiny was idle because it doesn't
actually know where you want to start
i find starting at the end was
where i launched react log was
too far away
because most likely i want to build up
into the unexpected era or build up into
what i'm trying to learn about the
application
so i started it at the first stable
location
and stable is kind of when most of the
outputs or in this case all of the
outputs and reactive values are green
they're in the ready state
if they were
not in the ready state and they're
actually performing some calculations
they'll be yellow
um
it's kind of useful uh to see these
different states in the future i'd
actually like to show more states like a
red for an error occurred or something
like a wreck false
but you know
i was just trying to show currently what
shiny is aware of because technically a
wreck false is a valid result and so
it's not calculating anything it is
actually ready to move on even though
the value
is not what we want so it'd be better in
the future if we could differentiate
those
so now we're at an idle and let's take a
peek at what happens when remember i
change the bins in the plot
so in the sidebar i change the um
oh this where the width actually changed
probably due to
the
the width
of the plot actually was changing
probably due to this
little showcase mode on the side
and so two times the plot was redrawn
because the output width
changed
and so
yeah so let's walk actually through when
i change the the int of the bins
and so i changed it from 30 to 21
and the way shiny works is all
downstream
uh dependencies will be invalidated and
they will remove all connections both up
and down stream
from their connections
so it's not fully invasive but it is
invasive for everything downstream of
this input value
so let's kind of walk through it
this will tell so the input bins will
say hey all my downstream listeners you
are now should start invalidating so
plot output
or plot object will start invalidating
he's going to tell of his downstream
dependencies which is going to be the
output disk plot
output this plot says okay i will start
invalidating
they will start invalidating by removing
all upstream dependencies so the black
lines are now becoming thin little lines
the thin lines i i kept in there to say
a connection has occurred in this
recording but it is currently not there
where if it's a thicker line then that
means it's actively
a dependency
okay this plot has removed all
connections and it is invalidated
um so now we are backing out of our
invalidating process and plot object
will
remove its last dependency and is now
finally invalidated and then the input
value
is done and so it will just
automatically jump over into the next
step which is the output starts
calculating
shiny works
in a
model where
it finds all the data that it needs to
render it is not necessarily a push
model so i did not push input bins into
the plot object it's actually the plot
object is reaching up and finding input
bins
it's a little different than the way we
think about it it's
because of the two different steps
where the first part was input bins
tells all downstream to invalidate but
then it's a free-for-all finally now
output disk plot can then work its way
upstream until it's satisfied
so output disk plot starts calculating
says hey
i need the plot object
plot object says i haven't calculated so
i need to start calculating
then it says well i don't have
everything i need i need a connection
too
in this case
it's these unexpected three items here
the client data output disk plot width
client data output disk plot height and
also client data pixel ratio
these three pieces of information are
necessary to draw an image in shiny
and i think it's really neat because
if you
squeeze the plot we should redraw it
because it doesn't really look like it's
going to fill the proper area if you you
know make the plot taller we will want
to redraw it so your output height and
width will change and then your pixel
ratio is if you actually do like command
plus or command minus
and you know you go to retina display or
non-written display the quality of the
image will need to be adjusted
and so in this case plot object is going
to be retrieving those values
um via an isolate that's why it has a
dashed line so it's isolating on the
value
and then it removes the connection
because an isolation does not have any
reactivity
and then we get the pixel ratio value
and the input bins
at this point plot object said hey i got
all my values i'm calculated so we can
go back to the disk plot and continue
the calculations
in this case
this plot
does have a hard dependency on the
output disk plot width the height and
the pixel ratio
mentally thinking i thought it would
actually be inside the plot object but
it just happens to be in the output this
plot
this plot is now satisfied and it is
done calculating
all of the outputs have now been
calculated
so therefore shiny is idle
uh
yes it was it happened at 11.45
and it's
finished at 11.51 so six hundredths of a
second yeah so the timeline across the
top does not represent actual time it
represents steps taken
and so you can have many steps taken in
a very short amount of time and you can
have hardly any steps taken in a very
long amount of actual time
um
such as when i go from
this step
yeah and this was um we were talking
about there
the
time up here represents the time since
recording or starting the application
and then the session represents what
shiny session it belongs to
typically when you open up a react log
that session will be isolated to any
global sessions such as shiny idle
or any
session that i i am running in so in
this case i'm running in the shiny
session 2d7 blah blah blah
and between these two steps about 10
seconds had elapsed
so the shiny was idle at the one second
mark and then we started changing the
value 10 seconds later
um and just a quick
to show about switching between idols so
if we do
um
yes if we click the button here we can
go back and forth between idle sessions
most likely that's something where you
know that you've done something within
the application
the graph doesn't necessarily change
because the app is fairly small
and the last one that i want to show in
this is the searching
so you can search for these labels here
um so in this case i can search for
let's say
plot and all the things that show up
or even capital plot
these three items all contain a capital
p in plot and
this is a smaller app so the searching
isn't quite as effective but if i did
the lowercase plot
um it's still the same graph because the
ancestors and descendants are the same
another way to go around this
i like to hit escape to escape that
searching that was done
another fun one is that you can double
you can single click an item so it kind
of shows up
while you move around and do things so
you can see that one specifically
escape to get rid of it but what i like
to do is to double click
and it will kind of make it bigger it'll
highlight it and it will find all of its
ancestors and descendants its whole
family tree
and when you move
back and forth it will only be
for that tree that is displayed so if
there are other reactives you have a
thousand other reactives above or below
that aren't shown we'll skip over all of
them so we'll only look at the
reactivity for the sub tree that is
displayed
and that is really useful because when
you have an app like gradient
i think on load
it has about 2500 reactive
uh ids created yeah it's it's big it's a
very big app um
it's wonderful for testing by the way uh
thank you um and
has a lot of different corner cases but
uh
yeah it's a very large graph very
shallow graph actually i was very
surprised about that
not very many uh you know dependencies
you know something like this like three
layers deep
but
useful nonetheless
so let's look at a more direct example
looking at
pythagoras
app
and i like to look at this one
as an app that people aren't necessarily
familiar with because we know the
pythagoras theorem we know how to
calculate it but we can do this through
reactivity
because if i change a or b then my
output c should also update you know
just that's how the definition of the
triangle is done
and
let's look at the
how we would calculate
pythagoras theorem
so
to calculate that we need to first
calculate a squared
we can label it with a squared and i
highly recommend you giving
anything that you can a label
because most likely you'll have a
multi-line expression and
possibly your first few lines might be
very similar to other reactive
expressions
and so your label default label is not
going to be that useful
instead we know this is a squared so i
can give it a nice value of a squared
this is underutilized but is very
effective when viewing the react log so
future u will thank you for your work uh
that you do up front
so we have a squared calculate
we then have b squared and we calculate
it great given these two reactive values
we can retrieve them
add them together to make c squared
and then finally given c squared
we can take the square root of it and
have our answer c
this value is then displayed via render
text and also a render print just so
that we have more
outputs to look at but it could just be
done with a single render print or
render text
okay so let's run this application in
the top i have a react log react log
enabled to enable the reactivity
and then finally i will call command fn
f3 just to open up the viewer so let's
run the application
cool
so this is a fun surprise i skipped over
in the code
you don't necessarily need to always
open up the viewer instead what you can
do is add a ui value and a server value
the ui value is react log
react log module ui so it's a ui module
that you can add into your application
just so it's inserted it the react log
is inserted in
and you don't need to open up in
multiple pages
but to pair with this we need to have
the react cloud module server so that we
can update those values
in the ui it won't magically just occur
shiny needs to be told that these things
can be done
so that's where that's coming from so in
our application we have our a we have
our b
and we have our c you know output c and
output c two different outputs and the
react log
looks like this
so we have a to a squared
b
to b squared
a squared and b squared makes c squared
c squared can be square rooted into c
and c is then stored in the output
c verbatim and c text
and that matched exactly how we had in
our application
a
input a to a squared input b to b
squared a squared and b squared point
into c squared and the square root of c
squared makes c and that matches our
labels everything is nice and tidy and
we can see our images right in the app
very exciting
um you'll notice that there's this extra
item of a theme counter
that's for things like bootstrap lib
where we update the theme and do things
like that you can feel free to ignore it
it's not a big deal
and then this extra line here
is the um
react log module ui and the iframe
because this is actually an iframe to
the reac log information
so we can just kind of feel free to
ignore that that's not a a big deal
okay so
let's look at
what happens when we change this to
5 and 12.
we get the 5 12 13 triangle great not
too big of a surprise
let's refresh our react log because that
info more reactivity has occurred
and it only loads it up to the first
time when we did um
the application when it was idle so we
can walk through this application
um using our arrow keys and when we
change the value a went from three to
five so all the down streams get
invalidated
and they're invalidating by removing all
of their dependencies and marking
themselves as invalidated
and then they work their way back up
and b squared was not a direct dependent
or descendant of a so therefore b
squared will keep its value but it will
just remove the connection from b
squared to c squared c squared is
actually initiating that removal of the
connection
and so b squared is going to stay
calculated and if you were to ask its
value it would return immediately it
would not need to recalculate because it
was not invalidated
and then once all of those invalidations
occur shiny sits there and goes okay
what outputs need to be calculated and
we'll walk through that again
so c verbatim says hey i need a value it
captures c
c needs to work its way up because it
doesn't have a value a squared works its
way up gets a
calculates its value c squared is now
happy with a squared but it also needs
to be squared
b squared in this case has already been
calculated so it returns its value
immediately no time is spent calculating
b squared
up the tree back down to c verbatim see
verbatim is happy but we still have more
outputs to calculate
so we'll move on to see text see text
will then look at c and say hey i need
your value c will be like great here's
my value we're done
there's no more calculations needed
shiny has this
automatic kind of caching value already
done
and so if a reactive value has not been
invalidated it will return its value
immediately and no time is spent
calculating that
and i think that's just great like it's
a neat little trick
hidden underneath and if you were to add
an output dynamically like right now
and all it needed was the c value and b
squared it would be instantaneous you
wouldn't have no extra overhead and that
is great
and then we're done shiny is idle
but we also then updated the value to 12
and we ran through the same process
again but we went up the b branch
instead of the a branch
done
shiny as idle
and then the next steps actually are me
clicking the refresh button and then the
iframe
updating
um
when you click the refresh button though
there
it will always go back to that first
idle location
and
the react log is append only i don't cut
it i don't do anything special i just
depend on because i don't want to hide
the truth from what's there from you
so what you can do is actually mark a
time point and i find this really useful
because
most likely in your shiny application
you will
have to do many steps to possibly get to
your bad reactivity
and then you'll say hey
i need to like mark this time point
because i know the next steps that i do
may be a little you know wonky
so to mark a time point you can do
command fnf4 or a little bit more
reliable given your browser you can do
command shift fn f3 so very similar to
command fn f3 but you add in the shift
and what this will do is it'll mark a
time point
so when we refresh our application
it won't load
to where it's first idle it'll load
to the left to the last marked time
point so you can have many marked time
points but it'll load the last one
and
this is really nice because um if we go
back to like a three
um
four triangle right so three four five
and then i refresh
it was loaded up before i hit that
before refresh and so we can go
i'm sitting in a 5 12 you know 13
triangle
and if i were to
um if i were to move forward this is now
uh
running through
and converting it back to the 3 4. so
right where i last marked my time point
so for completeness i'm going to do
another marked time point and i'm going
to refresh the react log
so you can see
the marked time point down here and i
can actually jump between them
using the
the black bar because that is a marked
time point
maybe we should remove them
uh unless they're there but i thought it
was kind of to help show that it's
possible that they could be there
okay so let's look at a situation where
react log will help us debug our
reactivity we had our pythagoras
application here and now let's look at a
broken one
so the difference between pythagoras and
pythagoras broken is not that much the
app will run
and
no errors will be produced
this is actually terrifying because this
means it's a logic error and it is not
actually a shiny error
so let's go ahead and run the
application with our react log enabled
all right so we're running our
application
great
so
what is going on here our c value is 4.2
it is not a 3 4 5 triangle
and
c squared is listening
listening to b squared sometime because
there's a connection being made
but
it's not solid
and what is
what and b squared is listening to a
this is weird so let's change it to a
5 and 8 12.
still
seven okay
so odd
all right so let's
look
at this application so did did actually
it changed yeah if i change b
nothing happens
so this isn't good either
so
walking through the react log let's kind
of see what happens here so this is when
i was changing it into that three four
five triangle so
a changed into or a five twelve thirteen
so a changed into five great
a is telling b to invalidate that seems
odd
so oh there it is input a is b squared
uh we should switch that
so that is now b
so
personally
that's a better logic change let's just
uh rerun the application here
so we'll run app again
okay things are looking better switch
this to a 5
and then we switch this to a 12
and b is still broken
that's not good but
we can see that b squared
is taking an input from b so that seems
better
so we're doing better there
so let's um walk through
that adjustment
so given that adjustment
3 turned a turned into 5
a squared c squared okay everything's
good
seems right output c verbatim is
recalculating getting its a squared
and c squared is
isolating
on b squared odd and moving on
okay so that
so there is that that's how that
connection was made at some point but
it's not
connected right now
and i guess that's why it makes sense
that when b changes its value all the
way up to anything like 20
c is not changing
so ah
isolate value here
we remove that b squared great
so we'll save it
let's kill the application
because we made a
known logic change that's better
and
things l i believe will be good so 5
and
12.
5 12 13 triangle
and if we refresh
our react log
we can see that a makes its updates
and we can also see
that
we change b
and it'll make its updates
and c was actually updated twice which
is what we want for all the changes of a
and b and shiny's idle
so that's how we can use it to help
debug and
it's helped debug logic changes and this
works really well when your application
is very large because this can work with
a couple thousand of these
different reactives no problem
just to show a bigger application
i'd like to look at the cran wales demo
app that joe showed at one of his
keynotes
so
again
we're going to make sure that
we're going to make sure that react log
is enabled we're going to run
the github
one
application and this application shows
the top n downloaders of all of crayon
that's hosted by rstudio
and it's usually the 80 20 rule where
like
six people are responsible for
a lot more than 20
or 80 percent of the traffic you know
depending on the day
so we're thinking about it here
and downloading that data
great all right so the data has shown up
we have some numbers up at the top of
the bandwidth consumed the files
downloaded the unique downloaders
so out of the 120 000 down unique
downloaders
the green bars are represented by six
people
so these are the whales and so it's the
crayon whales
and um yeah that's that's a almost fifty
percent by those six people
um
the biggest whales uh are given random
names and so the full puppy
he's the biggest whale
and by hour is actually very interesting
there's different behaviors um full
puppy looks kind of like internet
traffic
the glamorous parakeet pretty consistent
and
the glamorous fish very spiked behavior
and immense zebra looks very constant
so it's very interesting to see as to
how these different behaviors come about
and then we can look in the detailed
view of let's say a full puppy
and it's doing some calculations
and
either way
yeah so
um moving on uh so let's look at the
react block so the command fn f3
this is a lot bigger
um
we have a so this is the first time that
shiny was idle
and we are looking at the
remember on that home screen
we had three numbers up at the top and a
plot
so we have our outputs that have
calculated we have the
um
we have the total size okay we have the
total account
and we have the total number of
downloaders great and then finally
there's this plot output called all hour
and i'm recognizing this as a plot
because it's listening to the client
data pixel ratio the height and the
width
and there's a plot object as as well so
that's kind of like the shape of an
output plot
these all listen to a data set called
wales
which listens to the top
n or the top count and also what date
and i think that's really kind of neat
that you can see your data everything's
kind of pointing to these whales
and then things come from there
so we can actually look
yeah so it's me
then the next thing that i did is i
clicked on the second tab
so the second tab
will start and
um
let's see here and this will calculate
output downloaders
so output downloaders then says hey
i now exist
so let's make a plot because the output
downloaders
wanted to look at the biggest whales
it's just the single plot
and it runs through gets the plot object
plot object gets all of its information
and it pulls out the whales whales is
already calculated so we don't need to
recalculate it so it just takes the
value
right away
and then the plow output downloaders is
done
and then this happens again for the next
uh
two or three tabs oops i was hovering
sorry
and then the uh detail size detail count
detail unique
because
the whales by our
detail view that was a very big plot
took it took a little bit of time to
show up
but we had the
given full puppy this is the traffic
that they were doing
very funny
uh
not very many
1800 unique packages but downloading
them constantly so someone had a wild
true download file
um
yeah so
so we're going to go through here
so that's how the the plot information
will show up
for that one piece of information
and
if you noticed there was actually a blue
state a frozen state and that's what
happened with one of the input values
that we froze
so let's zoom back see if we can find it
quick
there it is frozen
this input details was frozen because
uh we're trying to avoid a situation
where if you have if you open up a new
view but you haven't had all of your
selected values like actually selected
then you may want to freeze that input
value
so that your plot doesn't error out
you can do this with maybe like a rec
false instead that would cause it to
update once the input value does but you
still may
need this special case of frozen
so if this does like if you have this
funny situation with plots and you can
see it just for a quick second
uh maybe check out
uh
something about freeze reactive values
and you can see more information in the
docs there
it's a rare situation but
it does happen
and then last i want to show that
ability to do the subsets
so we were looking at all hour to begin
with that was that home screen
so we can double click on all hour
and
all of the right and left keyboards
you know so i'm actually going to jump
many many steps in the react log because
nothing occurred on this subset
but if i back up just a little bit then
hey everything starts updating quickly
white
just to see these here white values are
reactive values that
will exist eventually but do not
currently exist
so input count has not been touched up
to this time point
um
and now it finally has at this time
that's why i kind of like to show it
when it's first idle because
everything's kind of stable just for a
little bit
one thing to look for with react log
because you'll find some shocking
behaviors every once in a while
and this is what uh joe referred to is
in one of his talks as an anti-pattern
and
basically what happens is
if you observe on something
like an input button
and you use a render method inside an
observer
this is typically bad there are there
are use cases like you add a new tab
where like it has completely independent
reactivity
cool you should do this
but in this case
if i just want to render a plot to bad
pattern something that's a static name
and this expression will actually be
evaluated many times that is actually
making new render plots over and over
and over again
and that is bad
instead what we should do
is calculate some data such as a
click count
and call render plot and wait until the
input button has been clicked so like i
require the input button to be not zero
and then i'll give you the input button
like that was the goal of this thing
such as when the button is clicked
render the plot so instead we can say
make a reactive on input button that
says you require to be something truthy
or nonzero you'll have click count and
then we render the plot given the click
count
if you really wanted to be dynamic and
random you could do it using a dynamic
output id
that's okay um that's kind of like
inserting a new tab or doing something
that has completely independent reactive
logic
but the typical use case of like click
the button render the plot this is bad
and we'll see it in react log plain as
day
so let's click the button
okay click the button okay we got some
new plots let's actually
um take a look at this react log
and you can see that the react lock will
get taller and taller and taller
and this is because
we will have more and more outputs of
output dollar bad pattern
so let's move
move forward in the react log and
so we can see that output
this output bad pattern will be
calculated
at some point and then it's finally
calculated there great you know you
don't really notice it off of one click
but what if we clicked it one two three
four five times
and now let's refresh let's mark
this time point
marked great and let's refresh our
application
now our react log is a lot taller
and if we zoom in
we can see output bad pattern output bad
pattern output bad pattern
there's four of these five of these
and so i can search for that
and they're all making different plot
objects and they're all listening to the
same inputs
so this is not good
and none of the output bad patterns
exist at any one time like they're not
coexisting at any one time
and so this is an anti-pattern and
something to avoid
if you see it
it's not the worst but it does
it will cause issues after hours and
hours and hours
[Music]
you